All of us were exposed to wounds on our fingers or anywhere else on
Our bodies, and immediately that part of the body gets a bit
From redness, a bit of swelling, maybe some heat
Of course, there will be some pain that accompanies
What is happening there
In general, this group of symptoms we passed
They are known as inflammatory response, or you can
Say that there are some infections you get there
People have known about this, I think, really
Since they were injured
I think maybe with modern medicine, they become people
More accurate about the classification of symptoms
But this is nothing new to someone
To say that there is a type of inflammation gets or
Type of inflammatory response
But what I want to do in this video is to understand what
Cause these - I think we can call them (Macrosystems)
What happens at the cellular level?
Because, in fact, for an inflammatory response
Are mainly the primary field of battle
For our immune system
Our first line of defense is our skin or fluid on
Extra skin or mucous membranes, however
The inflammatory response is what happens when there is something
Beyond that
When we get a hole from a nail, or there is a kind of virus
Or bacteria that go beyond skin or mucus
Surrounds our membranes
So please ..
This is the battlefield, especially
The initial field of motion
So we prepare for the battle of immunity so we can see exactly
What happens with the inflammatory response
I want to be very clear
Immunology is still an incomprehensible science
It is an effective field of research
People are still discovering mechanisms
It is very complex
I'm sure we probably will study this
For a long time to come
So, what I'm talking about is just an overview
Just to know the public actors, you know in general
What causes redness, swelling,
Heat and pain
So let me paint some skin cells
So, to say that these skin cells
This is the total simplification
For everything, but they really only give an idea of ​​what
Being
So I will draw a cross section
If these are some skin cells in it, then I will b ...
If this is the outside world here
Outside world
Then between these skin cells, I will draw some other cells
We will talk about what they are doing
I will not go into huge details about it
Let us call this cell mast cells here
I will draw more mast cells
Maybe another one here
This is a fat cell
If you remember the videos about the work of the cell or bug
Phagocytosis, you will remember that there is one type called
Stem cells, they tend to appear near the skin
Appear near the areas you are facing
Outside world
So I will draw two stem cells and these
Also good at
Activation of auxiliary cells
Maybe I'll draw another stem cell here .. Here it is, this stem cell
These are called stem cells
They have nothing to do with the nervous system
It looks like it has ramifications for it
They call it radical, but it is actually corrosive
They are near the exterior facades
The parts are ingested and are good at displaying those parts
For T cells help .. until they are activated
The alarm bells are struck.
So the skin is normal and works happily.
This is the outer part.
Here is the fluid that is distributed between tissues
..
This is the luxurious name of the liquid carrier of good cells
Surrounded by other cells.
The cells do not direct directly
To the circulatory system
Oxygen goes from circulation to
Fluid between cells Finally
To cells ..
So everything is directed to the bristles .. but
The capillaries play a role in blood circulation.
So let me draw this ..
Instead of just painting it as a pipe .. I will
Draw cells in circulation
this is
Are the cells lining the circulatory system
Actually, cells are making walls
For capillaries
..
This is a cross-sectional drawing
And he painted it as a pipe.
It does not look like scraps.
Actually .. are pipes
Everything appears in a cross-section
These are wall and vessel cells
This, of course, is the flowing blood
It has red blood cells
..
These are red blood cells
And seems to be heading for that direction
In this aspect, cells are oxidized.
These arteries to carry the oxygenated cells, and veins in the case of the cells otherwise
Through loss of oxygen.
Of course you may have white blood cells
Inside you .. much less than the red number
But only to make sure they are in your blood cycle.
It moves according to the circulatory system
Which the heart pump work in it.
Under natural conditions ..
Gas exchange occurs between
Blood cells in the circulatory system and intracellular fluid
And some of the exchange of cells and proteins
We will now look at how this happens
If we get an outsider
For example, a person takes a nail and sticks it into a bovine fertilizer
And sting him.
To see what will happen
..
If someone sticks that nail in you
After stitches in that manure
Of course the screw became polluted
It carries a bunch of bacteria
Which were filled with manure
He did not choose the manure for no reason
It carries a large amount of bacteria
Once you touch the first line of defense of your immune system
In the first entry through his skin
Some things will inevitably happen
The bacteria will start in
Resurfacing within the liquid surrounding the cells
Which touched the bacteria ..
Maybe also .. Some cells have been eliminated.
And some of the skin cells as well
Skin cells begin directly in the secretion
Some chemicals.
this Materials
They are considered transportation vehicles
News about the exposure of some cells
To the infection of these exotic organisms .. First: the surrounding fluid
Something happened to me.
These materials are called chemical transporters
..
It is a general word that actually means
Small molecules or proteins produced by cells
As a type of coding signals.
"Chemical vectors" is a word consisting of two parts
She works as a "reporter"
They are moving.
So these substances are excreted.
It's enormously complicated.
So, what I'm doing now is very high-level information.
There are many types of "vector" polarizers.
And also we have these mast cells here, and this mast
It can be activated by possibly direct contact with
Rusty nail.
Can be exported from excreted polarizers
Of these cells.
Some of the particles can be released from
Actual bacteria.
These bacteria are also excreted by different derivatives
As soon as the body enters.
Any of the above can activate the mast cells
Hence, those mast cells secrete histamine.
..
You can now appreciate the high level of information
It's really complicated though
I think you become familiar with the subject.
If the word "histamine" is vague to you, it is not new
Maybe because you've had an anti-histamine one day ..
Perhaps in the past few months,
Especially during the cold season.
Histamine type is one of the main actors in
Inflammatory response, and when you have a cold ..
Gonorrhea, nasal obstruction, and similar symptoms
These are all deposits of inflammatory response.
Antihistamines are mainly used to mask
The symptoms respond without stopping their action.
But the question arises: Is it necessarily necessary?
Is it always a good thing?
Because, as I continue to talk about in this video, that is
First line of defense.
This is the first part of our immune system battle.
But anyway, so the histamine is one of the things that
It does it go to the lining cells
Of the capillaries, causing them to be separated away
From each other and make the actual capillaries bigger.
This is called vasodilation.
..
Suppose all of them have been activated with a little bit
Of histamine.
..
Histamine has been attended, so ..
The cells moved away from each other.
And go further and further
Until capillaries become larger than they are
..
So you happen to have swelling, because
Suddenly, the capillary tubes grew larger and more flexible
In fact, it returns to its normal size with time
The liquid is encouraged to assemble around.
This is called "vasodilation"
Another fancy word to describe
Increased volume of capillaries
She grows up ..
The liquid fills them.
Not only liquid, but
More red blood cells also.
There is a lot of fluid here, and white blood cells too
As porosity of the walls of capillaries increased.
Suddenly, all the parts that could not pass through the bristles previously
You will be able to pass now easily.
And one of those things that will be easier passed
During them - and again, remember, all
Other things happen.
Hystamine is submerged in these
The lining cells are probably some of them
Blood entry.
These polarizers are excreted from nearby cells
Of damage.
Green parts
Are produced by viruses
You have polarizers, which are blue.
They all come out here.
So the first responders, the macrophages, especially
And then neutrophils, which are the most abundant of
Phagocytes, "subclass of white blood cells", and they
These chemicals are attracted to.
They want to move in the direction of those
Chemicals.
Now that the vacuum between these capillary cells increases
They can pass through the walls of poetry.
So what they are actually doing - let's say this
Of neutrophils
..
Begin to roll over the walls
Which is called proximity.
And roll up
Stick to the wall.
They stick to the wall, and then eventually press
Through these gaps in the wall capillaries.
This is called leakage.
Sometimes it is called emigration.
These are all luxury words, but basically mean
Pressing the walls.
These are neutrophils
Hence, of course, due to vasodilation,
Where neutrophils will leave here
Exactly where it is needed.
These neutrophils will move here and there
Will do its job.
They are going to swallow some of these bacteria
Start to eat up, maybe even some
Damaged cells here.
This is what you want to happen.
That's why it's called the battlefield.
At the same time, your cross-sectional cells,
And other phagocytes, will eat up viruses and so on
It exists on its surface.
And it is not just the neutrophils that come here.
For this is a place to be consumed and all this
Liquid is gathered here, you will also have B cells and
T cells help that will also make their way.
They will also get close to the walls, where they are
They are rolling too ..
They leak
And act and do
Specific immune system.
That's the whole point here.
This is the reason why the video delays the inflammatory response
Because it is not a simple thing.
It is actually a battlefield where all actors are
Come play its role, even the first line to defend your skin,
All actors,
The inflammatory response is usually categorized
Not specific because it will occur regardless of anything
But you have non-specific actors like
Neutrophils.
And the immune system identified as your B cells and T cells
You also have an unspecified supplemental system.
I will not go into details here, but you have
Some of the proteins that flow in your blood plasma that
Usually in an inactive state, but when infections occur
A response occurs, .. These proteins usually act
(This process is not explained 100% so far)
After activating the sniff
These are derivations
Very helpful in helping too
Many killed
Bacteria in this case.
This is the supplementary system ..
It's really just a group of proteins that
Floating in the blood .. and form a defensive line the first good
Unspecified against certain harmful objects that invade our bodies
So hopefully this gives you a good sense of what is going on
In the inflammatory response.
As you can imagine, you have all those fluids that flow
And all that blood that flows here.
You have all of these fluids ..
And those cells that move from capillaries to
Ambient fluid means entering the inside
This fluid is called "secretions".
..
So this whole thing is about swelling and redness
Therefore, this is what you notice with your naked eye
Of symptoms.
Anyway, we hope that what we have provided has been useful to you ..